ach du scheiße das buch ist durchsichtig
ist und ich zu haue ich direkt wegkomme
müsst euch das angucken immer das
programm bisher hat der mann laut ist
lea im inventar und wenn ich drüber
versteht gut st 1 aber das buch
existiert nicht ist durchsichtig
unsichtbar zum hallo an alle zur
nächsten folge mit dem thaddäus müssen
wir vor mir steht ja und wenn gemachten
foto sk von abzappeln wir wollten gerade
dadurch gehört wir müssen das besser
machen geht mir gut
wir brauchen einen ort ein ort hier am
tisch weil ich brauche hier wird genau
werfen einfach alles so kommt auch
einfach hier nachsehen diamanten
ich habe beides alte alter alter alte
alter ok ja ich gebe dir alter wiese ich
hab dir das falsche buch geben scheint
sich auf die wasserqualität gegeben ist
das wollte ich hab kein buch einstecken
das hat das erstmal gut samt altherr
bewusst meine abwasser affinität
gesamtheit billig 10x hertha steht da
drauf
er wird auch zu mir hab ich doch ich
hab's oder eingeworfen irgendwo hier
liegt das schloss das inventar sogar
aufgenommen als neuer champion momentan
warte ich hab das hierhin gebracht das
habe ich in der aufnahme drin ich habe
meinen rucksack drin oder so ich hab
keinen rucksack an
ich hab das hier hingeworfen alter ohne
witz ja lass es jetzt alter ich habe das
wirklich in wolfsburg ich habe kein buch
jetzt komm ich gebe jetzt erstmal ganz
großen diamanten zurück ich habe das
wirklich eingeworfen alter wenn das
jetzt weg ist
ich habe keinen verzaubertes buchmann
inventar drin
walter ich habe meinen jetpack drin ich
habe hier oben der ersten reihe ein
bisschen steinzeug dabei dieses
verzauberte buch habe ich effektiv nicht
mehr drin
das sind die endlichkeit so lange hier
zu schnell dass ich kann ich nicht
spielen
jung gewusst das buch kann sein dass du
das weggezaubert hast nein ich kann
nicht zaubern
ich dachte schon ich kann nicht mal die
minimum cherry einsammeln obwohl völlig
ich kann diese schädlichen freien platz
erringen ach du scheiße das buch ist
durchsichtig ist und ich glaube ich
direkt wegkomme müsst euch das angucken
immerhin das buch ist leer hat der mann
laut ist lea im inventar und wenn ich
drüber verstieg gut samt 1 aber das buch
existiert nicht durchsichtig unsichtbar
ja hallo ich komme es im tagebuch du
hast dich gerade einfach verpissen es
ist unglaublich dass das können wir
nicht übernehmen
cook zwei jahren die aufnahme und
schickte die aufnahme bei youtube hoch
ja man sage ich ja legal für dran ist
aber hier ist das komplett leerer slot
und wo halt nicht drüber verstärkt seit
1 das bringt den sommer wasser aktivität
das ist aufrüstung style oder wasser
fini thet ist auf rüstungsteile das ist
ganz auf den helm drauf machen kannst du
dinge atmen
solaris natürlich bands ohne helm
unterwegs war musste er steckt als
softie schaden ein
weil ja ich glaub ich machen brauchen
hat es euch sagen der dinge hat eine ist
ohne das hat nur auflagen als effekt
drauf ich habe etwas affinität
das bild kann auch so wird's gemacht
hast ja ich hab jetzt werde ich gar
nichts gemacht
also wenn du dich wieder angezogen viel
zu wenig meinen bronzehelm hab ich was
affinität erst eins drauf gepackt auf
meinen helm und dann ich hatte zwei
bücher mit wasser affinität 1 180
wasserqualität 2 ich habe mich
vielleicht und übrigens gekillt sich so
oder so nicht nur das war ein bisschen
zu schatten der aber trotzdem diese
tatsache dass direkt angreift erhöhe
bleibe weil ich hab das buch sogar
hingeworfen dort auch aufgenommen doch
weit weg
ich habe es nicht gesehen das sind exakt
gleich mit mir nicht drin ist existiert
nicht machen macht mit den amboss drei
eisen blöcke und vier eisenbach 3 skype
nachrichten
ich kann nicht meine ende machen ambros
ist ja gar nicht so ich muss auf deutsch
schreiben da amboss
naja ok genau genau genau habe ich
dennoch reisen hier ich oft mal genug
wenn ich das doof ich kann doch
theoretisch in diesem minimum steigeisen
herstellen auch noch da du bist du weißt
ja ich sehe gerade was lena hier
geschrieben hat ja was ja den neuen klug
sind bisschen so tief aber die
diskutieren über die wichtigkeit von
mega projekte also was ich jetzt machen
wollte entweder solar also enorm boss
habe ich jetzt entweder ein solar helm
oder halt diamanten hin sparen
allerdings diamanten ist doch eigentlich
besser wieso hat keine so viele käfer
doch gar nicht gezaubert jetzt
angefangen mit zauber nachdem er
allerdings schon 26 diamanten hatte die
kann man sich herstellen aus gold aus
gold
der mund wenn man genug materialien hat
natürlich ein stein
ich muss mal gerade echt hier glaube ich
bald auf dem standardtext speck wechseln
weil ich sehe ich dieses buch mache ich
das sitz in mini um stein wirklich mag
ich sie um jegliche kraft was ich den
mini umstadt ich schaue da bin ich mir
auf hilfe angewiesen stein haben und
träger steiner stellen
hier stein für eisenbahn
so viel stein
experience extrakte generated als trader
konstant raus ins tor allerdings tut so
was emma stone ending story trailer
genau dann kommt steuer sandro vier
steine noch aus ich brauche ein bisschen
kohle ab dann kriege ich wieder gemmel
spring von level zu level zu level
sozusagen ja lassen lied er weiß ich ja
gesagt so zu sagen ja sagt jetzt bist du
ein alter sack das was ich denn bloß
weil ich hier die alttiere etwa fünf
jahren hast du jetzt habe ich mich nie
um stein mit dem jetzt machen ach so ja
stimmt ja man hat auf einem steinigen
gearbeitet das ganze zeit zehn sekunden
so und jetzt auch noch gold
diamanten hergestellt aber nicht gemacht
gold hergestellt
die hohe muster dem spricht nur noch
gold für haye wenn ich wie nie um stein
in der hand hat ja dann ist unten rechts
mini umstadt und ich kann auch sachen
draufklicken heavy ist die komische ist
ich hab keine ahnung damit kennt sich
auch noch nicht wirklich erwartet ich
gebe dem minimum stein kurz in der hand
drücken irgendwo drauf aber halte ich
habe ja noch unter der erde warcraft
persson ab ich will gar nicht oben
so ist mein level zusammen kann gleich
wieder zurück aber weiß was man schon
mal dabei bin
die zustände durch jetzt ist dem stein
er hat mehr gebrauchen ja denn kinder
brauchen red skull gruselig
spark ja wenn man einen diamanten blog
abbaut
ich will dir button klickt man daraus
diamanten erdloch oder diamanten kann
ihr mann ihr blog von diamanten blog was
du findest unter der nähe denen man sich
aus den diamanten crafted diesen blauen
block christen 9 alter wie geil ein
minimum dein und viel gold blöcke und
ich hab so ein ja wohl ganz genau soviel
goldbarren machen das genau gleich dort
geht alles schneller
was genau der gleiche stand wie wenn der
in konstanz nimmst du brauchst halt
weniger aufladung von dem links nur
wenig verbrauch weniger mini um steine
ja meine ich ja weniger auflagen von
minimum stein
die freunde
wo ich wäre eigentlich wieder level 6
ich kann das oben verzaubern
für den weiteren ressourcenabbau mache
sehr wenig denn da wieder die diamanten
raus aus dem diamant block im film krans
crafting feldwegs lhg beiseite stellen
scheint ja wann ich habe elf jahre alt
erhält für mich ist das jetzt halt die
schnauze für mich ist das gut und
neuaufbau elf stück erhaltet ihr konntet
ihr nur täglich gleich malta dass wir
nicht sehen geschlossen ich bin froh
dass er keiner vorher hier sagt direkt
erstmal diät gemacht
das musst du selbst rausfinden
wieder ausrastet
bis aber die spur als schuhe
ich komme ich behaupte ja genau so hat
jedoch zu viel wechseln
ich bin ich auf eure hilfe anbietet muss
die raman spitzhacke machen ob sie ihn
abzubauen
und alle die beim micra zu fuß auf nur
das machen dann kann ich genauso abbauen
sie konnte das opfer nur zum rate ich
vielleicht genauso 8 und warte warten
wir jetzt gleich der der angeber pro
trick den cancan über mir sehen achtung
data recorder tagen nicht zu erwarten
weil sie konnten sie auch fertig habt
gerade 35 ob sie den abgebauten in zwei
sekunden gerade wildtiere sind in der
truhe alle biere weg so ich habe jetzt
erst mal von ihrer arbeit kommt die
andere pro track und dann drüber
jub
heraus gekommen hier und da stecken wir
noch fast aufgeladen komplett
dann haben wir zufällig gerade in
gegnerisches wetter oder so weit ist
weiß ich nicht also ist hier die längst
nicht alle dinge sehen und so links
nicht dingen sind schließlich das
passiert oft männer um eine map packs
umfasst der ich verbrauche ziemlich viel
energie er gerade irgendwie gut 1000
fliegen mit einer klappe schlagen aber
nicht so gut wie viel braucht eigentlich
nur ein mattem alu vollblut zeigt jetzt
ein mal eins und einmal gibt 2 du musst
zwei machen zwei dort wuchs die muss man
zusammen krank ist europa von schon raus
so plastisch vor einzelnen ich als supa
was du anziehen kann sondern ganz eins
im komplett ein
ich hab's ja freunde jasper ich bin
stolz auf mein nach diamanten gratis
sind
was zähle war das denn das glaubt ihr
nicht
jetzt sollst du nicht heraus meinte der
mann schweige unsichtbar gewesen
ich habe die ganzen tage zum haben sie
rausgeflogen einfach so unrecht zu recht
14 17 spitzhacke und dann könnt ihr die
bücherregale abbauen hoffe ich mal ohne
sieg und gehen
nein die gtz warum internet nein
andersrum geht es gar nicht mehr
verzaubert warum die verzauberung ist
weg der untergang von der spitzhacke
aber ich habe meine sechs level bezahlt
alter ich habe kann ich nehme mit
behutsamkeit verzaubert in dem in dem
amboss ups heraus genommen haben daraus
geblockt und nicht mehr runter es ein
gesamt ich habe es wieder das buch hier
einst sind ich habe das buch wieder los
die spitze aber die level sind weg das
gerät immerhin ja also das ist ja ein
wiki frecher den puck abgebaut dafür
dass du mir so angeberisch bist hier v8
das fahrrad ist das ist keine verarsche
das ganz einfach der plan von minecraft
und mir dich nach und nach ganz
zerbersten auseinanderzunehmen
das ist
hat sich das büchergeld wieder trafen
czeka gefunden oder so was es sagt ja
schon wieder runtergefahren
ich habe gerade sechs leveln
zusammengefahren auch diesen aufnahmen
zu sehen
glaub ich es ja
ja
hey ich hab zwei long vollmuth die ach
so ja die muss jetzt noch zunehmen das
inventar ton stimmt
jetzt kann ich als ich war schon
überrascht der onyx so das heißt wenn
ich jetzt mein jetpack aufsetzte ja ja
was ich muss gut überlegen ich muss mir
gefällt herr holen ich rede nicht mehr
mit ihren kleinkrafträdern weiter bogen
fressen dich nämlich jetzt runter so
jetpack geht jetzt mal ganz hoch man
hört zwar noch den schaden
was passiert nichts mehr
wie
164 von dem weg vom ihr business park
ein bisschen kaputt aber freundes wird
was man so etwas liest ich komme die
anderen kamera die den besucher ich
jetzt erst mal kannst du tun wenn du bis
vier tiefen nächste verzauberung was ich
gerade als nächstes brauch zu verlieren
durch cooles egal welche türen man jetzt
einfach hat oder ich brauche moskau
gerade glaube ich mal zum austesten ob
das geht hat machen können wir machen
sind nämlich jetzt schon 17 minuten da
ja schon erst die letzte folge ich mir
immer wieder anlass das kratzt displays
okay dann sehen uns im nächsten partner
gucken ist ein mit leicht verdienen
aufnehmen und dann würde ich sagen
schüsse